imagine
you're walking through a forest i'm
guessing you're thinking of a collection
of trees
what we foresters call a stand with
their rugged stems and their beautiful
crowns
yes trees are the foundation of forests
but a forest is much more than what you
see
and today i want to change the way you
think about forests
you see underground there is this other
world
a world of infinite biological pathways
that connect trees and allow them to
communicate
and allow the forest to behave as though
it's a single organism
it might remind you of a sort of
intelligence
how do i know this here's my story
i grew up in the forests of british
columbia
i used to lie on the forest floor and
stare up at the tree crowns
they were giants my grandfather was a
giant too he was a horse lager
and he used to selectively cut cedar
poles from the inland rainforests
grandpa taught me about the quiet and
cohesive ways of the woods
and how my family was knit into it
so i followed in grandpa's footsteps he
and i had this curiosity about forests
and my first big aha moment was at the
outhouse by our lake
our poor dog jigs had slipped and fallen
into the pit
so grandpa ran up with a shovel to
rescue the poor dog
he was down there swimming in the muck
but as grandpa dug through that forest
floor i became
fascinated with the roots and under that
what i learned later was
the white mycelium under that the red
and yellow mineral horizons
eventually grandpa and i rescued the
poor dog
but it was at that moment that i
realized that that
palette of roots and soil was really the
foundation of the forest
and i wanted to know more so i studied
forestry
but soon i found myself working
alongside the powerful people in charge
of the commercial harvest
the extent of the clear cutting was
alarming
and i soon found myself conflicted by my
part in it
not only that the spraying and hacking
of the aspens and birches to make way
for the more commercially valuable
planted pines and furs
was astounding it seemed that nothing
could stop
this relentless industrial machine so i
went back to school
and i studied my other world
you see scientists had just discovered
in the laboratory in vitro
that one pine seedling root could
transmit
carbon to another pine seedling route
but this was in the laboratory and i
wondered could this happen in real
forests
i thought yes trees in real forests
might also share information below
ground
but this was really controversial and
some people thought i was crazy
and i had a really hard time getting
research funding
but i persevered and i eventually
conducted some experiments deep in the
forest
25 years ago i grew 80 replicates of
three species
paper birch douglas fir and western red
cedar
i figured the birch and the fur would be
connected in a below ground web
but not the cedar it was in its own
other world
and i gathered my apparatus and i had no
money so i had to do it on the cheap
so i went to canadian tire
and i bought some plastic bags and duct
tape and shade cloth
a timer a paper suit a respirator
and then i borrowed some high-tech stuff
from my university
a geiger counter a scintillation counter
a mass spectrometer microscopes
and then i got some really dangerous
stuff syringes were full of radioactive
carbon 14 carbon dioxide gas
and some high pressure bottles of the
stable isotope carbon 13 carbon dioxide
gas
but i was legally permitted
oh and i forgot some stuff important
stuff the bug spray
the bear spray the filters from my
respirator
oh well the first day of the experiment
we got out to our plot
and a grizzly bear and her cub chased us
off
and i had no bear spray
but you know this is how forest research
in canada goes
so we came back the next day and mama
grizzly and her cub were gone
so this time we really got started and i
pulled on my
white paper suit i put on my respirator
and then i put the plastic bags over my
trees
i got my giant syringes and i injected
the bags
with my tracer isotope carbon dioxide
gases
first the birch i injected carbon 14 the
radioactive gas
into the bag of birch and then for fur i
injected the stable isotope carbon 13
carbon dioxide gas
i used two isotopes because i was
wondering whether there was two-way
communication going on between these
species
i got to the final bag the 80th replica
and all of a sudden mama grizzly showed
up again and she started to chase me and
i had my syringes above my head
and i was swatting the mosquitoes and i
jumped into the truck and i thought
this is why people do lab studies
i waited an hour i figured it would take
this long for the trees to suck up the
co2 through photosynthesis turn it into
sugars
send it down into their roots and maybe
i hypothesized shuttle that carbon below
ground to their neighbors
after the hour was up i rolled down my
window
and i checked for mama grizzly oh good
she's over there eating her
huckleberries
so i got out of the truck and i got to
work i went to my first bag with the
birch i pulled
the bag off i ran my geiger counter over
its leaves
perfect the birch had taken up the
radioactive gas
then the moment of truth i went over to
the fir tree
i pulled off its bag i ran the geiger
counter up its needles
and i heard the most beautiful sound
it was the sound of birch talking to fur
and birch was saying hey
can i help you and fur was saying yeah
can you send me some of your carbon
cause somebody threw a shake cloth over
me
i went up to cedar and i ran the geiger
counter over its leaves
and as i suspected silence
cedar was in its own world it was not
connected into the web
interlinking birch and fur
i was so excited i ran
from plot to plot and i checked all 80
replicates
the evidence was clear the c13 and c14
was showing me that
paper birch and douglas were in a lively
two-way conversation
it turns out at that time of the year in
the summer that birch was sending more
carbon to fur than fur was sending back
to birch
especially when the fur was shaded and
then in later
experiments we found the opposite that
fur was sending more carbon to burst
than birch was sending to fur
and this was because the fur was still
growing while the birch was leafless
so it turns out the two species were
interdependent like yin and yang
and at that moment everything came into
focus for me i knew i'd found something
big
something that would change the way we
look at how trees interact in forests
from not just competitors but to
cooperators
and i had found solid evidence of this
massive below ground
communications network the other world
now i truly hoped and believed that my
discovery would change how we practice
forestry
from clear-cutting and herbiciding to
more holistic and sustainable methods
methods that were less expensive and
more practical
what was i thinking i'll come back to
that
so how do we do science in complex
systems like forests
well as forest scientists we have to do
our research in the forest and that's
really tough as i've shown you
and we have to be really good at running
from bears
but mostly we have to persevere in spite
of all the stuff stacked against us
and we have to follow our intuition and
our experiences and ask really good
questions
and then we gotta gather our data and
then go verify
for me i've conducted and published
hundreds
of experiments in the forest some of my
oldest experimental plantations are now
over 30 years old
you can check them out that's how forest
science works
so now i want to talk about the science
how were paper birch and douglas for
communicating
well it turns out they were conversing
not only in the language of carbon
but also nitrogen and phosphorus
and water and defense signals and
illegal chemicals and hormones
information and you know i have to tell
you before me
scientists have thought that this
below-ground mutualistic symbiosis
called a mycorrhizae was involved
mycorrhizae literally means fungus root
you see their reproductive organs when
you walk through the forest
they're the mushrooms the mushrooms
though are just the tip of the iceberg
because coming out of those stems are
fungal threads that form a mycelium
and that mycelium infects and colonizes
the roots of all the trees and plants
and where the fungal cells interact with
the root cells there's a trade of carbon
for nutrients
and that fungus gets those nutrients by
growing through the soil and coating
every soil
particle the web is so dense
that there can be hundreds of kilometers
of mycelium under a single footstep
and not only that that mycelium connects
different individuals in the forest
individuals not only of the same species
but between species like birch and fur
and it works kind of like the internet
you see like all networks mycorrhizal
networks have nodes and links
we made this map by examining the short
sequences of dna
of every tree and every fungal
individual in a patch of douglas fir
forest
in this picture the circles represent
the douglas fir or the nodes and the
lines represent the interlinking fungal
highways or the links
the biggest darkest nodes are the
busiest nodes
we call those hub trees or more fondly
mother trees because it turns out
that those hub trees nurture their young
the ones growing in the understory
and if you can see those yellow dots
those are the young seedlings that have
established within the network of the
old mother trees
in a single forest a mother tree can be
connected to hundreds of other trees
and using our isotope tracers we have
found that mother trees will send their
excess
carbon through the mycorrhizal network
to the understory seedlings
we've associated this with increased
seedling survival
by four times now we know we all
favor our own children and i wondered
could douglas fir recognize its own kin
like mama grizzly and her cub so we said
about
an experiment we grew mother trees with
kin and stranger seedlings
and it turns out they do recognize their
kin
mother trees colonize their kin with
bigger mycorrhizal networks they send
them more carbon below ground
they even reduce their own root
competition to make elbow room
for their kids when mother trees are
injured or dying they also send messages
wisdom onto the next generation of
seedlings
so we've used isotope tracing to trace
carbon moving from an injured mother
tree down her trunk into the mycorrhizal
network
and into her neighboring seedlings
not only carbon but also defense signals
and these two compounds
have increased the resistance of those
seedlings to future stresses
so trees talk
thank you
through back and forth conversations
they increase the resilience of the
whole community
it probably reminds you of our own
social communities and our families
well at least some families
so let's come back to the initial point
forests aren't simply collections of
trees
they're complex systems with hubs and
networks
that overlap and connect trees and allow
them to communicate
and they provide avenues for feedbacks
and adaptation
and this makes the forest resilient
that's because there are many hub trees
and many overlapping networks
but they're also vulnerable vulnerable
not only to natural disturbances
like bark beetles that preferentially
attack big old trees
but high-grade logging and clear-cut
logging
you see you can take out one or two hub
trees but there comes a tipping point
because hub trees are not unlike rivets
in an airplane you can take out one or
two and the plane still flies
but you take out one too many or maybe
that one holding on the wings
and the whole system collapses
so now how are you thinking about
forests differently
cool i'm glad
so remember i said earlier that i hope
that my research my discoveries would
change the way we practice forestry
well i want to take a check on that 30
years later here in western canada
this is about 100 kilometers to the west
of us just on the border of banff
national park
that's a lot of clear cuts in my
estimation there hasn't been a lot of
change in the last 30 years
it's not so pristine in 2014 the world
resources institute reported that canada
in the past decade
has had the highest forest disturbance
rate of any country worldwide
and i bet you thought it was brazil
in canada it's 3.6 per year
now by my estimation that's about four
times the rate that is sustainable
now massive disturbance at this scale is
known to affect hydrological cycles
degrade wildlife habitat and emit
greenhouse gases back to the atmosphere
which creates more disturbance and more
tree die backs
not only that we're continuing to plant
one or two species and weed out the
aspens and birches
these simplified forests lack complexity
and they're really vulnerable to
infections and bugs
and as climate changes this crew is
creating a perfect storm
for extreme events like the massive
mountain pine beetle outbreak that just
swept across north america
or that mega fire in the last couple
months in alberta
so i want to come back to my final
question
instead of weakening our forests how can
we reinforce them and help them deal
with climate change
well you know the great thing about
forests as complex systems
is they have enormous capacity to
self-heal
in our recent experiments we found with
patch cutting
and retention of hub trees and
regeneration to a diversity of species
and genes and genotypes
that these mycorrhizal networks they
recover really rapidly
so with this in mind i want to leave you
with four simple solutions
and we can't kid ourselves that these
are too complicated to act on
first we all need to get out in the
forest
we need to re-establish local
involvement in our own forests
you see most of our forests now are
managed using a one-size-fits-all
approach
but good forest stewardship requires
knowledge of local conditions
second we need to save our old growth us
these are the repositories of genes and
mother trees
and mycorrhizal networks
so this means less cutting i don't mean
no cutting but less cutting
and third when we do cut we need to save
the legacies
the mother trees and networks and the
wood the jeans
so they can pass their wisdom onto the
next generation of trees
so they can withstand the future
stresses coming down the road
we need to be conservationists
and finally fourthly and finally
we need to regenerate our forests with a
diversity of species
and genotypes and structures by planting
and allowing natural regeneration
we have to give mother nature the tools
she needs to use her intelligence
to self-heal and we need to remember
that forests aren't just a bunch of
trees competing with each other
they're super cooperators
so back to jiggs jigsaw's fall into the
outhouse
showed me this other world and it
changed
my view of forests i hope today to have
changed how you think about forests
thank you